this is a true story of how a fat man is
going to lose all of his weight that's
right you just might see some blood
sweat tears and I just might [ __ ] myself
a little little gulp oh jeez Oh what is
going on my little sugar boogers welcome
to a new series my friends that I am
pretty excited to share with y'all now
for majority of my life I have been fat
now whether it was 20 to 30 pounds
overweight here and there is something
that I have struggled with for a
majority of my life and yeah it's been
weighing on me you know literally and
figuratively now before we go ahead and
jump into the purpose of these videos
let's go ahead and talk about this
relationship that I have with looking
like Kim Jong Il's long-lost son for me
being fat has been something that I have
identified myself with and I know that
sounds stupid but it's true now this
begs the question why the [ __ ] would I
identify myself with being the fat guy
right now for a majority of my life I
have always been known as Big Dave you
know except for a couple years out of my
life right really focused on fitness but
because I was always known as big day
being fat has always been a part of my
identity and even when I was doing
stand-up it was a huge part of my comedy
I accepted the fact that I was fat and
even though I really didn't enjoy it I
took it in as a part of who I am so fat
became synonymous with David now let's
fast-forward to actually go back in time
to a few years ago now if you guys don't
already know just kidding films has been
a huge part of my life here in LA and
when it comes to fitness bart has played
a huge role just to let you guys know on
a side note if you haven't seen Bart's
channel Bart is a [ __ ] fitness animal
I have a theory that has not been proven
yet but I believe that Wolverine and
she-hulk one day had a baby on the side
and fart Kwan was thus born I call this
workout death this [ __ ] crazy
now if you guys don't know this already
Bart is by far one of the most humble
nicest most intelligent people that I
ever met but because he's so buff one
time I try to pay for his meal again and
he told me not to he told me he was
gonna kill me and I know he was joking
but even though he did um my pain
shovelled up into a little peanut M&M
sector into little cashews I think I
grew a vagina I'm joking but I hurt
inside mmm but anyways being around Bart
has flipped my perspective on a lot of
things and specifically on why I choose
to be fat now notice what I said that I
said the word choose which means that me
being fat has always been a choice I
remember I told him once that if I was
to fit that I wouldn't be a comedian
anymore
and what he told me that day was that it
wasn't true then it wasn't my weight
that made me funny
it was my humor that made me a comedian
it's funny because the moment he said
that I realized how emotionally
dependent I was on being overweight if I
could explain it it's almost like the
fatter you are the less people expect
out of you so you kind of find comfort
in that mediocrity so from now on I will
be keeping you guys updated on my
fitness progress every week every
Wednesday from now on and I've said this
before but I want this bad I have never
wanted this more than my life than I do
now and if you guys don't know this
already about me but I want something
get it let me tell you something my very
first girlfriend before we got together
rejected me three times and let me tell
you something I award that [ __ ] down
like the grandmother [ __ ] Kenyan she
said yes she loved me
she didn't know at the time until we got
together and I touched the boobies
that's right hell yes this specific
video set is here to inspire I'm not
gonna go in and talk about all my used
to B's and where I was before all I know
now is that I'm [ __ ] fat I'm out of
shape and it's time for that [ __ ] to
change so any of you out there that want
to make a change with me and suffer
along with me please do this with me
make your own video count go ahead and
start your own vlog series I don't care
just do this with me and I guarantee we
don't get a baby on these videos I will
be talking about fitness how I feel
emotionally physically what I'm doing to
lose weight and you guys can check my
progress it's for accountability I'm
gonna tell you guys this right now there
are so many things in life that are
mediocre so when you see something that
you want you take what you deserve so
you already know what it is let's get it
Oh what is poppin YouTube now remember
what I told you guys you guys will be
getting a fitness video every Wednesday
from here on out so remember to check it
out mmm you will hear exactly what an
overweight feb and is going to go
through to lose his weight and no it's
not gonna all be positive because this
is gonna feel like [ __ ] so stay tuned
and please do this with me if you guys
want remember you guys to use the
support and I can't to clothing of
course is always brought you by go for
pro apparel hot fresh this is a wisdom
floral design right here and the hot
biscuits red [ __ ] you're playing so
Fitness fam I'll see y'all next week
giggle attiny with living like this